before you debuted had you ever like
performed on a big stage before or
anything like that no my first
ever concert in my entire life was in
front of two thousand people
wow a solo concert gods and so
when the when the curtain went up i
almost like
right there so like i almost died on
stage
what's the biggest crowd you've ever
performed in front of um it was at an
event and and that so that was uh
probably like so 10 000
somewhat number of people wow but when
it
becomes that sort of number you can't
see the faces so it's like a sea
of lights and like pen lights so it
you don't become nervous anymore it's
just like when it's
it's more nerve-wracking when you're in
a small venue
and you see every single face and
they're all looking at you
it's the eye contact they're really that
really gets you high five fine
because we don't have that experience i
mean like what's the biggest amount of
people saying on a planet
x right ax i think i mean i hosted in
front of like three things yeah two or
three thousand people
and that i was [ __ ] my pants yeah i
hate it when you
make eye contact with someone for like
two seconds and you're like do you
reckon they noticed
they're 100 percent notice that was that
weird that was weird right you imagine
doing a panel in front of 10
000 people i would like to not yeah i
would like to not either
i gotta ask do you ever get is it is
like do you ever get nervous before
going on stage do you ever get used to
that
um i'm not a huge person like a nervous
person
so i'm usually pretty like excited to go
on stage
right and i'm like i'm gonna have fun
this is my home you know
yeah so i i really don't get nervous but
when i do get nervous though um
you know uh it doesn't it's every time i
do get a little bit nervous
yeah i love being on stage because i i
feel for me it's it's i don't know if
it's nerves but i just
i just it's the waiting that kills me i
just want to get on stage whenever
whenever i have like a panel scheduled
or whatever and there's a lot of people
i just feel like
once i get on stage i'm gonna be fine
but before that i'm just i'm just
restless
it's like it's like you're backstage and
you just hear the murmur of the crowd
right that's
when it's the most nervous but the
moment i start like going up the stairs
it's just it's just gone that's exactly
true like i hate the waiting of it the
waiting is the most nerve-wracking
point once you're on stage then you just
got to do what you got to do so yeah
did you discover like the first time
you're on stage was it like a
aha moment this is i love this oh i
thought yeah
this is definitely where you know i want
to be i'm i'm
so grateful to have this chance to
actually do what i love doing
and i don't know it's just i'm so
this is perfect you know for me because
i i assume it's kind of like a trial by
fire because
you said you had no stage experience
before because like i can only imagine
some other artists who
just kind of didn't take to the stage as
well would uh
would have would have would have fallen
flat i went on stage
in japan for a video recently where i
like did like a visual k
video and um it was awful i hated it
because it was like it was like 30
people so it's very intimate right and
like yeah
because it also covered no one was
allowed to like move everyone just had
to stand
yeah which makes it even worse because i
wasn't doing anything right i was just
head banging but any time i stopped and
made even like
a millisecond of eye contact with
someone and they were just like
i was like oh my god i'm awful i'm
terrible i'm ruining the whole thing
um yeah needs to say i was i was uh not
happy about it
it's like it's like doing a performance
in front of your family right and
they're just like being here yeah
but at least your family you know your
family's gonna have your back no matter
what
i figured out when i have to go on stage
and do something to actually be good at
it
that's when i get nervous because i'm
like i have people have expectations
like it's okay to be bad at it and like
that's the whole joke
uh yeah i like that because it's like
all right i'm just gonna be a clown
that's what they can do
that's what i'm good at i guess that's
like the the benefit of like you know
doing a panel for us
most if not all the people who are
attending it know us
enough that even if we [ __ ] up slightly
they'll be like that's just
him you know i have no talent so what am
i going to do on stage
[Music]
i've only really you know my career took
off in japan
right yeah i'm not an american-based
singer but at the same time i grew up in
america
and i've been going to concerts in
america and i did realize after my debut
that the japanese sort of entertainment
industry is completely
different from the american hundred
percent 100 different and
the sort of um expectations in japan are
very high you have to be
perfect you know a lot of people are you
know require perfection as
part of the job so right um that is
always very nerve-wracking to be able
to have to sort of think oh you know i
have to perform perfectly on stage but
that's impossible
i feel like it's even like that when
you're ordering a drink at starbucks
here they think
they have to oh my god they're gonna
hate me i didn't put the little straw in
and it's like no no it's okay i feel so
bad they're freaking out